.
Hier habe ich einen Jungen
gezeichnet, der keine Hand hat.
Hier ein Mädchen,
das keine Beine und keine Hand hat.
Ich habe Flugzeuge gezeichnet
und geschrieben:
"Nicht gut, Bombe."
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Und ich habe ein Mädchen gezeichnet,
das froh ist.
Darunter schrieb ich "Schweiz".
* Hohe, bedrückende Klänge *
(Junge) Manchmal sahen
meine Mutter und ich die Flugzeuge,
wenn wir einkaufen gingen.
Dann rannten wir
ganz schnell nach Hause.
Ich schaute immer meine Mutter an
und sie war jedes Mal
den Tränen nah.
Sie rannte und rannte,
aber dann konnte sie nicht mehr.
Darauf betraten wir einfach
ein fremdes Haus.
Wir wussten nicht, wer dort wohnt.
Wir hatten grosse Angst.
Ich schaute meine Mutter an und
fragte: "Warum geschieht das jetzt?"
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Warum passiert uns das?
Warum müssen wir flüchten?
Warum findet dieser Krieg statt?
Und warum ... Warum muss ich das
jetzt alles erleben?
Daher kann ich ...
... das sehr gut verstehen.
Ich fühle mit ...
... den Ukrainern und allen,
die zurzeit Krieg erleben.
* Tiefes Einatmen *
Egal, welche Nationalität sie haben.
Wie sich die Bilder gleichen ...
Familie Nasser flüchtet schon 2013
vor dem Krieg in Syrien
in die Schweiz.
Sie ist Teil einer Grossfamilie
von insgesamt 17 Personen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Eine Woche nach ihrer Einreise
in die Schweiz begannen wir,
die Familie mit der Kamera
zu begleiten.
Das Asylzentrum Lyss
ist ihre erste Unterkunft.
Schon innerhalb Syriens
waren sie drei Jahre auf der Flucht.
Hier starten sie erneut -
in jeder Hinsicht - bei null.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
* Lachen *
Ich bin froh, froh, froh.
Warum?
* Er spricht arabisch. *
(Vater) Weil ihr gekommen seid.
Fünf Monate sind vergangen.
Kusais und Judis Mutter Raoaa
war in Syrien Lehrerin
und hatte einen guten Status,
viele Freundinnen, ein schönes Haus.
Kurz: ein gutes Leben.
Jetzt nutzt sie jede Deutschstunde,
die sie und ihr Mann
im Asylzentrum belegen dürfen.
Brot.
* Er spricht unverständlich.
Alle lachen. *
(Gebrochenes Deutsch) Schreiben
klappt gut, aber sprechen ...
... little. Very ...
Ihr Sohn Kusai ist neun.
Kriegsbedingt konnte er in Syrien
nur ein Jahr lang zur Schule gehen.
"Guten Morgen."
"Hallo, Thomas."
(Langsam) "Ich bin Frau Maier."
Nach zehn Monaten im Asylzentrum darf
Kusai mit anderen Flüchtlingskindern
die Primarschule in Lyss besuchen.
Sprachlich ist er seinen Eltern
schon weit voraus.
"Am Montag gehe ich in die Schule
und am Dienstag auch."
"Am Mittwoch gehe ich in die Schule
und am Donnerstag auch."
"Am Freitag gehe ich in die Schule
und am Samstag nicht."
"Am Samstag und Sonntag
habe ich frei, juhu."
* Lachen *
Was ist hier anders als in Syrien?
Es ist viel schöner und besser.
Die Kinder schlagen einander nicht.
Die Lehrerin und der Lehrer
sind viel besser.
Seine Schwester,
die fünfjährige Judi, und die Eltern
verbringen ihre Tage
wartend im Zentrum,
in der Hoffnung, bald in eine Wohnung
transferiert zu werden.
Nach zweieinhalb Jahren
verlassen Kusais und Judis Eltern
das Asylzentrum
als Letzte der Grossfamilie.
Ihre erste Wohnung in der Schweiz
hat drei Zimmer, ist günstig
und liegt am Rand von Köniz
in der Nähe von Bern.
Physisch sind sie in Sicherheit.
Hört der elfjährige Kusai
ein Flugzeug, zuckt er zusammen.
Nachts versteckt er sich oft
unter dem Bett.
Ich träume, dass ich in Syrien bin
und dass Leute sterben.
Ich wache jede Nacht
etwa zweimal auf.
Wenn ich Angst habe, hilft mir ...
... das hier.
Das stammt noch aus Syrien.
Hast du es mitgenommen?
Ich möchte Arzt werden,
damit ich Menschen helfen kann.
Ich habe gesehen,
dass einige Leute in Syrien
wegen einer kleinen Schussverletzung
am Arm starben,
weil es keine Ärzte mehr gab.
Denn viele
haben ja das Land verlassen.
Wenn ich Arzt bin,
werde ich das nie tun.
Ich werde die Leute
nicht einfach sterben lassen.
Fast alle Schweizer denken,
dass wir Terroristen
und keine guten Menschen sind.
Ich möchte sagen, dass ...
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es
nicht auch solche Syrer gibt ...
... aber es sind einfach
nicht alle so.
Meine Finger
sind auch nicht alle gleich.
Das ist auch ...
Auch nicht alle Menschen
sind gleich.
Und wie geht es Ihnen beiden?
Wollen Sie die Wahrheit hören?
Oje. Das ist sehr schwierig
zu sagen.
Also, die Wahrheit:
Gott sei Dank sind wir
zurzeit in der Schweiz
und nicht in Syrien.
Und ...
Aber wir sind nicht glücklich.
Das Leben ist sehr schwierig
ohne Sprachkenntnisse,
ohne Arbeit,
ohne Beschäftigung und ohne Freunde.
Besonders die fehlende Arbeit
ist ein Problem.
Wir sitzen den ganzen Tag herum und
wissen nicht, was wir tun sollen.
Wie gross sind unsere Chancen,
Arbeit zu finden?
Lass jetzt meine Haare in Ruhe.
Das hättest du gern.
- Stimmt.
Sie können
kein normales Leben führen.
Sie sind dauernd am Handy
und schauen sich Nachrichten
aus Syrien an.
Warum wollen sie wohl wissen,
was in Syrien geschieht?
Ja ...
Sie denken viel darüber nach.
Es ist nicht gut,
so viel nachzudenken
und sich dauernd
damit zu beschäftigen.
Das ist nicht so gut.
Sie sind immer unglücklich und ...
... haben keine Lust,
etwas zu machen.
Meine Mutter will sich am Handy
dauernd die Nachrichten ansehen.
(Schrei aus dem Handy)
Was machst du?
* Arabische Musik aus dem Handy *
Das ist wichtig.
- Ja, aber ...
Wir können es
nicht einfach vergessen
und hier ein schönes Leben führen.
Verstehst du, dass er sagt:
"Ich will nicht mehr"?
Ja, das tut weh.
* Stimmengewirr aus dem Handy *
* Schreie,
bedrückende Musik aus dem Handy *
* Schreie *
* Ein Kind ruft etwas auf Arabisch. *
* Ein Kind ruft etwas auf Arabisch,
bedrückende Klänge *
Was wir gemacht haben ...
* Ein Kind ruft etwas auf Arabisch,
bedrückende Klänge *
* Die Musik bricht ab. *
Judi zeichnet inzwischen keine Bomben
und keine Kinder ohne Beine mehr.
(Kinder) # Emia enza penza,
schugera schugera,
# mia mia plam plam plam,
questa tore, tore mio,
# tore mio platsch!
# Emia enza penza, schugera schugera,
# mia mia plam plam plam,
questa tore, tore mio,
# tore mio platsch!
Nein!
(Mädchen) Egal, komm wieder rein.
Machen wir einen Neuanfang?
- Nein.
(Lehrer) WP 36, Kurs 1. Voilà.
Das hast du schon korrigiert
und das auch auch.
Und die HA
hast du auch bereits gemacht.
Die Blätter sind dort.
- Gut, du hast sie schon reingelegt.
Es ist erstaunlich, was Kusai
in diesen zwei Jahren gelernt hat,
wie gut er Deutsch spricht und
versteht - auch Schweizerdeutsch.
Das ist total verblüffend.
Am Elternabend
sagte die Mutter, Frau Nasser,
dass ihr Sohn 10-14 Std.
pro Tag Hausaufgaben mache.
Ich sprach mit ihr darüber
und hatte den Eindruck,
dass sein Ehrgeiz und seine
Lernbereitschaft sehr hoch sind.
Aber er ist ein Kind.
Es ist enorm wichtig,
dass er in seiner Freizeit
draussen spielt.
Wenn er das jetzt nicht tut,
wird das nie mehr möglich sein.
(Lehrer) Wer hatte
sechs Punkte, sechs Richtige?
Gut, ihr könnt danach
ein Päckchen aus den verbliebenen
Panini-Bildern auswählen.
* Die Kinder
sprechen durcheinander. *
Was nimmst du?
- Ein Band und das hier.
Was bringt das?
Keine Ahnung.
- Tolle Bänder.
Ihr kennt Kusai gut, nicht wahr?
- Ja.
Beste Freunde.
Wart ihr schon mal bei ihm zu Hause?
- Ja.
(Leise) Er hat einfach
weniger Dinge als wir.
Mhm.
Wenn er bei uns ist, sagt er oft,
wir hätten sehr viele Dinge,
die er nicht habe.
Aber er ist ganz nett.
Denkt ihr, dass er sich
diese Dinge auch wünscht?
Nein, aber er findet sie schon toll.
Stellt ihr ihm
manchmal Fragen über Syrien?
Eigentlich nicht.
- Warum fragt ihr ihn nicht?
Weil wir denken,
dass das für ihn nicht gut ist.
Sagte er das?
Oder wieso denkt ihr das?
Aus einem Land zu flüchten,
ist nicht gerade einfach.
Das war für ihn wie ein Albtraum.
Das wollen wir
natürlich nicht wieder ...
Jetzt ist er in der Schweiz
und lebt hier.
Bern ist meine zweite Heimat.
- Wo fühlst du dich wohl?
In Bern.
Hier ...
... fühle ich mich einfach sicher.
Der Rosengartenpark in Bern
ist Treffpunkt
für die syrische Grossfamilie.
Hier trifft Kusai seine Verwandten.
Ein bisschen wie in Syrien -
für ein paar Stunden.
(Raoaa) Der Park
ist für alle in der Nähe.
Fast jede Familie ist
in 5 Min. hier - nur ich nicht.
Du brauchst von Köniz aus länger.
- Ja.
Aber ich komme gern hierher,
weil ich sie sehen will.
* Muntere Klänge, Kinderlachen *
Es sind weitere zwei Jahre vergangen.
Ausflüge kann sich die Familie
nicht leisten,
bisher haben sie
kaum mehr als Köniz und Bern gesehen.
Darum laden wir sie
nach Luzern ins Verkehrshaus ein.
Ich freue mich.
* Lachen *
(Mann) Ich gebe Ihnen die Tickets.
Sie können sich gleich
in die Schlange stellen.
Die Eltern haben in der neuen Heimat
kaum Schweizer/-innen kennengelernt.
Sie sind gehemmt wegen der Sprache
und es fehlt ihnen an Möglichkeiten,
um Kontakte zu schliessen.
Die Schweiz ist nach wie vor
ein unbekanntes
und ziemlich verunsicherndes Terrain
für die ganze Familie.
Das Matterhorn.
Berge finde ich sehr gefährlich.
Sie sind spannend,
aber sehr gefährlich.
Ich mag keine gefährlichen Dinge.
Insbesondere
diese Schweizer Karte ...
Dass diese Leute
nach ihren schlimmen Erlebnissen
nun in einem sicheren Hafen gelandet
sind, ist schon eindrücklich.
* Postautohorn *
Über die traumatischen Erlebnisse
wollen sie nicht mehr reden.
Die neue Kultur zu verstehen,
ist anstrengend genug.
* Münzenklimpern aus der Maschine *
Selbst Helikopter
hatten für die Flüchtlinge
eine ganz andere Bedeutung.
Bei uns gibt es viele,
aber nur Kampfhelikopter.
Keine Helikopter der Ambulanz.
- Keine Helikopter der Ambulanz.
Nicht zum Helfen, sondern zum Töten.
Aber jetzt tritt das
langsam in den Hintergrund.
Verändert sich etwas?
- Ja.
Wir sind nun seit
fast fünf Jahren in der Schweiz.
Eine lange,
aber doch keine lange Zeit.
Für mich fühlt es sich lange an.
- Als wären es 100 Jahre.
Aber die Erinnerungen bleiben.
Aber der 14-jährige Kusai hat
seine Angst vor Flugzeugen verloren.
Ob er als Arzt bei der Rega
arbeiten will, weiss er noch nicht.
* Helikopterlärm *
Im Oktober 2019 lebt Familie Nasser
noch immer in der gleichen
Dreizimmerwohnung in Köniz.
Mutter Raoaa hat seit zwei Monaten
eine neue Praktikumsstelle
als Betreuerin und Pflegerin
für geistig
und körperlich behinderte Menschen.
Judi ist Fünftklässlerin.
Gerne würde sie ab und zu eine
Schulfreundin mit nach Hause bringen.
Aber sie hat noch keine.
* Kuss *
Die Tasche kommt hierhin.
* Sie spricht arabisch. *
Mir geht es wirklich
viel besser als früher.
Ich habe mein Ziel ...
... noch nicht erreicht,
aber es geht mir viel besser
als früher und es wird immer besser.
Wir geben uns alle Mühe.
Ich bin sehr stolz auf meinen Mann,
weil er Arbeit gefunden hat.
Er hat Glück gehabt.
Er begann vor zwei Jahren,
in dieser Firma zu arbeiten.
Er ist sehr glücklich und stolz.
Ich habe auch
viele Fortschritte gemacht
und mir wirklich Mühe gegeben,
damit ich Arbeit finde.
Zurzeit mache ich
eine allgemeine Ausbildung,
damit ich nächstes Jahr
eine Ausbildung
für Erwachsene absolvieren kann.
Gleichzeitig arbeite ich ...
... als Betreuerin,
weil ich später eine Ausbildung
als Betreuerin machen möchte,
um in Richtung
Justizvollzug zu gehen.
Was ist das Ziel?
- Justizvollzug.
D.h., Sie würden in einem Gefängnis
arbeiten?- Genau.
Ich möchte in Syrien
wirklich etwas verändern,
da ich bereits ...
Ich habe so viele
schlimme Geschichten und Bilder
in meinem Kopf.
Die Menschen,
die in Syrien fälschlicherweise
oder aufgrund
eines Missverständnisses
ins Gefängnis kommen, gehen kaputt,
bevor man feststellt,
dass sie unschuldig sind.
Daher möchte ich in der Schweiz
unbedingt eine Ausbildung
im Justizvollzug machen,
damit ich in Syrien in diesem
Bereich etwas verändern kann.
Kusai ist inzwischen
in der neunten Klasse
und hat dort Kollegen gefunden.
Hallo, Kusai.
- Guten Tag.
Zu Hause habe ich
etwas mehr Verantwortung als früher.
Ich passe z.B.
auf meine Schwester auf.
Aber eigentlich
hat sich nicht viel verändert,
ausser dass meine Eltern
jetzt arbeiten.
Das finde ich auch besser.
Damit fühle ich mich auch besser.
- Wieso?
Es freut mich einfach.
Wenn sie arbeiten, sind sie
glücklich. Das freut mich für sie.
Auch für ihn ist es mit
Gleichaltrigen leichter geworden:
Meine Freunde in der Schule
meinten es gut, aber ...
... sie behandelten mich zu nett.
Dann fühle ich mich ja auch ...
... besonders.
- Ja, genau.
Das wollte ich nicht.
Aber jetzt
behandeln sie mich normal.
Ich bin ein Schüler wie alle andern.
Nun fühle ich mich sehr wohl.
Mein Bruder wäre
doppelt so schnell ...
* Lachen *
Hallo.
Ich bin in meinem Job
sehr glücklich.
Ich habe
eine gute Stelle gefunden ...
... und alle Kollegen
sind sehr nett zu mir.
Für mich ist es sehr wichtig ...
... Arbeit zu haben.
Aber leider arbeite ich
zurzeit im Stundenlohn.
Ich hoffe sehr, dass ich später
eine Festanstellung kriege.
Denn ...
... unsere ganze Familie
möchte selbstständig sein
und keine Sozialhilfe beziehen.
Sie brauchen monatlich
400 Fr. Sozialhilfe,
obwohl beide Vollzeit arbeiten.
Eine grössere Wohnung
bleibt deshalb noch ein Wunschtraum.
Hier schlafen meine Eltern.
Ich habe noch kein eigenes Zimmer.
Hier schlafe ich.
Dies ist mein Kleiderschrank
und hier habe ich
einen kleinen Schreibtisch.
Hier ist das Zimmer meines Bruders.
Eigentlich gehört dieser Bär mir,
aber ich habe keinen Platz.
Ich habe ihn
zu meinem Geburtstag bekommen.
Daher ist er in seinem Zimmer.
Hier ist sein Game-Platz.
Er gamt ja viel.
Und hier ...
- Er hat mehr Platz als du, was?
Ja, viel mehr.
- Warum denn?
Weil er etwas älter ist und
mehr Leute zu ihm zu Besuch kommen.
Bei ihm übernachten jeweils Freunde,
bei mir nicht.
Und hier ...
Sein Plüschtier hat er immer noch.
Und ... Tja.
Für die Eltern ist syrisches Essen
immer ein Stück Heimat,
die Kinder
bevorzugen inzwischen Fast Food.
* Entspannte Klänge *
* Lachen *
Jeden Morgen kurz vor 6 Uhr
fährt Ammar Nasser mit Zug und Bus
zur Arbeit
bei USM Haller in Münsingen.
(Durchsage) Aeschistrasse.
In Syrien war er Mechaniker
mit eigener Werkstatt.
Diese Arbeit ist fast so wie meine
Arbeit in Syrien. Daher mag ich sie.
Sie ist sehr interessant.
Zuvor habe ich
ein neunmonatiges Praktikum gemacht.
Es war eine kleine Werkstatt
wie hier, aber sie war älter.
Ein Freund von mir,
der hier arbeitet,
erzählte seinem Chef von mir.
Darauf lud mich der Chef
zu einem Vorstellungsgespräch ein.
Ich sprach mit dem Chef ...
... und kriegte die Stelle.
Ammar Nasser baut Möbel
im High-End-Bereich zusammen,
die er sich selbst
nie leisten könnte.
Wissen Sie, was dieses Regal kostet?
9'644 Fr.
Es ist sehr teuer,
aber die Qualität ist gut.
Vielleicht hält es 100 Jahre.
Er selbst verdient weniger
als die Hälfte davon im Monat.
Ungefähr 4'000 Fr.
Und das nicht mal garantiert.
Je nach Auftragslage darf er
mal mehr mal weniger arbeiten.
Sein grösster Traum
ist eine Festanstellung.
Solange ich genügend Aufträge habe,
können die temporären Mitarbeiter
arbeiten,
insbesondere die Leute,
die wie er schon länger hier sind
und wissen, wie es hier läuft.
Wenn sich die Situation verbessert,
wird die Festanstellung
wieder zum Thema,
aber zurzeit ist das nicht möglich.
Nicht nur das Einkommen zählt,
sondern auch die sozialen Kontakte
am Arbeitsplatz.
Gehen wir einen Kaffee trinken?
- Ja.
Gestern habe ich
schlecht geschlafen.
Ja?
- Ich hatte Stress.
Weswegen?
Keine Ahnung. Einfach so.
Hast du gestern lange gearbeitet?
- Nein, nur bis 15.45 Uhr.
15.45 Uhr?
- Ja.
Dann fuhrst du
mit dem Zug nach Hause?- Ja.
Ich habe kein Geld.
Du musst bezahlen.- Okay.
Nimm nur.
- Danke, Ammar.
Und du? Bis 15 Uhr?
Wann hast du angefangen?
Um 6 Uhr.
Vorn ist jemand krank geworden.
Zuvor montierte ich.
Seit Ammar besser Deutsch spricht,
getraut er sich jetzt auch,
Freundschaften zu schliessen.
Im Hip-Hop-Kurs ist auch
für die mittlerweile elfjährige Judi
das Soziale
mindestens so wichtig wie das Tanzen.
Der Besuch eines solchen Tanzkurses
wäre in Syrien
für ein Mädchen nicht denkbar.
Von Verwandten hört sie
hin und wieder kritische Bemerkungen.
* Lockere Popmusik *
Welche Note
hattest du im Englischtest?
Ähm, eine Fünf. Und du?
- Super. Eine Sechs.
Sie ist fast meine beste Freundin.
Ich habe mehrere gute Freundinnen.
Für mich ist sie auch
eine meiner besten Freundinnen.
Wieso macht es Spass?
- Keine Ahnung ...
Wir lernen neue Dinge.
- Wir können uns frei bewegen.
Ab und zu etwas Sport zu machen,
ist toll.
* Lachen *
Hallo.
* Jauchzen *
* Lachen *
Lisa ist unsere Mitte, okay?
Okay?
- Ja.
Erinnert ihr euch
an die Choreografie?- (Alle) Ja.
Okay. Ihr seid alle unten.
Den Blick nach unten.
* Lockere Hip-Hop-Musik *
* Die Musik bricht ab. *
Okay? Wir machen weiter.
* Lockere Hip-Hip-Musik *
Die Kinder
sollen eine Möglichkeit haben,
ihr Selbstbewusstsein zu steigern.
Es ist
ein unterschwelliges Programm,
in dem sie sich entfalten
und kreativ sein können.
Das Besondere an roundabout ist,
dass wir mehr als
nur körperliches Training anbieten.
Nach dem Training
gibt es einen gemütlichen Teil.
Dann können sie miteinander plaudern
und über Dinge sprechen,
über die sie anderswo
nicht sprechen können.
Gehen wir nach hinten?
Okay, hier ist
nicht gerade viel Platz.
Was hattest du?
- Das hier.
Ich schlief heute
im Unterricht fast ein.
(Leiterin) Wer möchte
als Erste etwas erzählen?
Mia.
Ich wählte dieses Smiley, weil es
heute in der Schule sehr lustig war.
Es war einfach cool
und wir hatten nicht so viele Tests.
Das ist schön.
- Ja.
Ich mag auch nicht zu viele Tests.
Ja, Judi?
Ich habe dieses Smiley gewählt,
weil ...
Es fühlt sich an,
als wäre heute ein ...
... verrückter ...
- ... verrückter Tag.
(Leiterin) Ein verrückter Tag?
- Ja.
Tschüss.
Bis nächste Woche.
Judi.
- Tschüss.
Hey.
* Sie sprechen arabisch. *
Wir lernten einen neuen Tanz für
einen Auftritt im Juni oder Juli.
Wo?- Ich glaube,
auf einer Bühne in Wankdorf.
Dann müssen wir auch kommen.
Ja, du und Mama und Papa
müsst kommen.
Okay.
Sie fürchtet sich immer im Dunkeln.
Es ist auch ein bisschen gefährlich.
Daher hole ich sie immer ab.
Was ist denn gefährlich?
- Dass sie allein im Dunkeln ist.
Manchmal habe ich weniger Angst
und sage ihm,
er solle an einem Ort warten,
wo ich Angst kriege.
Z.B. beim Kreisel oder so.
Und dann tut er das?
- Mhm.
Und wenn du keine Zeit hast?
- Dann kommt Papa.
Am Dienstagabend
bin ich eigentlich immer zu Hause.
Was habt ihr gemacht?
Mutter Raoaa hat oft Früh- oder
Spätschicht in ihrem Betreuungsjob.
Deshalb wechseln sich die Eltern
mit der Kinderbetreuung ab.
(Ammar)
Du musst ein bisschen warten.
Okay.
Manchmal geht sie
um 11 oder um 9 Uhr aus dem Haus.
Manchmal muss sie auch ...
... früh los, so wie Papa.
Bereitest du immer das Essen für
die Kinder zu, wenn Raoaa weg ist?
Ja.
Wenn Raoaa da ist, auch.
(Lachend) Nein.
Ich arbeite viel zu Hause.
Du bist in dieser Hinsicht
schon etwas Besonderes, nicht wahr?
Ich glaube schon.
- Für einen syrischen Mann.
Für einen arabischen Mann.
Ja. Tun das arabische Männer
nicht so oft?
Nein, bei uns sind nicht alle so.
Aber für mich ist das kein Problem.
Machst du es ganz gern?
Ja, aber nicht immer.
* Lachen *
* Entspannte Klänge *
Guten Appetit.
Gleichfalls.
Ende 2019
lebt Familie Nasser erstmals
eine Art schweizerische Normalität.
Das Coronavirus breitet sich
in der Schweiz weiter aus.
Der Bundesrat
beschloss neue Massnahmen.
An Schulen wird bis am 4. April
nicht mehr unterrichtet.
Läden geschlossen, die Schule
fällt aus, die Grenzen sind dicht.
Die Schweiz stemmt sich mit
aller Kraft gegen das Coronavirus
und der Bundesrat greift zur dras-
tischsten Massnahme: dem Notstand.
Raoaa Nasser
trifft es gleich am Anfang hart.
Obwohl sie kaum aus dem Haus geht,
wird sie im April 2020
positiv getestet
und muss mit schwerem
Krankheitsverlauf ins Spital.
Ein Schock für alle.
Ich dachte darüber nach,
was wegen des Coronavirus
mit dieser Welt passiert ist.
Das Ganze verletzt mich
und macht mich sehr wütend.
Meine Mutter nimmt die Coronaregeln
und Regeln im Allgemeinen
extrem ernst.
Mein Vater eher weniger.
Meine Mutter kriegte das Coronavirus
trotzdem, mein Vater nicht.
Dass meine Mutter
das Coronavirus hatte,
war wirklich sehr schlimm für uns.
Zuerst musste sie
zehn Tage lang im Spital bleiben.
Nein, ich glaube, sie musste
acht Tage lang im Spital bleiben.
Danach musste sie noch
zehn Tage lang in Selbstquarantäne.
Das war wirklich schlimm.
Wir durften sie nicht umarmen
und sie durfte nicht mit uns essen.
Das war sehr traurig für meinen
Vater, meinen Bruder und mich.
Hallo, Mama.
* Beide lachen. *
Wie geht es dir im Moment?
Mir geht es eigentlich super, danke.
Ich kann nur noch nicht ...
... riechen und schmecken.
Aber das ist ja nicht so schlimm.
Es bessert sich langsam wieder.
Und wie ging es dir,
als du das Virus hattest?
Hm ...
* Seufzen, Lachen *
Das war nicht so lustig
und ziemlich mühsam.
Ich hatte auch grosse Angst,
weil ...
... in Bezug auf dieses Virus
alles so unsicher ist ...
... weil es noch nicht
viele Forschungsergebnisse gibt
und alle ziemlich verloren sind.
Man weiss nicht, was noch passiert.
Das machte mir Angst,
obwohl andere,
die das Virus hatten ...
... noch in einer schlimmeren
Situation waren als ich.
Aber es machte mir trotzdem Angst.
Nun zeige ich euch,
was mein Bruder so macht.
Er gamt nämlich die ganze Zeit.
* Lärm aus dem Computerspiel,
Kusai spricht unverständlich. *
Hallo, Papa.
* Lachen *
Hallo, Judi.
Ich habe eine Frage:
Was stört dich
an dieser Corona-Sache?
An Corona stört mich ...
... dass ich
meine Stelle verloren habe.
- Ganz verloren oder ...
- Ich bin jetzt immer zu Hause.
Hast du sie ganz verloren
oder ist es nur wegen Corona?
Ich weiss es noch nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Wenn das Coronavirus weg ist, kriege
ich meine Stelle vielleicht wieder.
Bist du traurig,
dass du nicht mehr arbeiten kannst?
Ja, sehr.
Ein Mensch ohne Arbeit
ist kein Mensch.
Aber wenn du zu Hause bleibst,
ist das besser für mich.
Für dich, aber für mich nicht.
* Seufzen *
Hallo zusammen,
ich mache jetzt Hausaufgaben.
Mein Vater ist in seinem Zimmer
und schläft.
Mein Bruder ...
... gamt oder lernt.
Ja, ich glaube, er lernt.
Ich will nicht
in seinem Zimmer lernen.
Meine Mutter
ist auch hier im Wohnzimmer.
Aber sie muss wegen
meiner Mathematik aber leise sein.
Ich muss jetzt Mathe machen.
Ich fühle mich gerade,
als würde ich allein mit Maschinen
in einem Wald leben.
Als ob es gar keine Menschen gäbe.
Das finde ich total blöd.
Jetzt muss ich lernen.
Ihr wisst ja, wie das ist:
Meine Mutter besteht auf Regeln
und sagt,
ich müsse lernen,
die Zähne putzen etc.
Falls jemand zuhört,
der Mitglied im Bundesrat ist:
Bitte öffnet die Schwimmbäder,
bitte.
* Entspannte Musik *
Kurz vor den Sommerferien.
Die Zeugnisse der Kinder
lassen die Sorgen vergessen.
In Mathe habe ich eine 4,5 und sonst
habe ich überall eine 5 oder 5,5.
Du warst in Mathe
nicht so gut wie ich.
Aber dafür hast du
in Musik eine 4,5.
* Raoaa lacht. *
Und ich eine 5,5. Was ist?
Was sagt die Mama dazu?
- Das ist super.
Ich finde es wirklich super
und ich freue mich.
Es überraschte mich ein bisschen.
Ich war mir nicht sicher,
ob sie gute Noten haben würde.
Sie spielt sehr gern
und konzentriert sich nicht so ...
... gern lange.
Ich habe mich getäuscht
und bin überrascht,
dass sie trotzdem
so tolle Noten hat.
* Lachen *
Ich war besser als du.
(Lachend) Judi, ihr seid beide gut.
Das ist doch auch super.
- Es ist okay.
Nein, das ist doch sehr gut. Super.
Es ist okay.
Okay, Judi,
ich habe dir nachher 20 Rp.
Hey!
- Sorry, 20 Fr.
Nein.- Du kannst es
nachher mit Mama anschauen.
Also, 20 von dir und 50 von dir.
Du bist gleich gut wie Kusai.
Daher kriegst du
genau gleich viel wie Kusai.
(Ammar) Fast gleich gut.
Doch, genau gleich gut.
Sie ist super.
* Sie macht freudige Geräusche. *
Freust du dich?- Ja.
Nun absolviere ich
die Wirtschaftsmittelschule
mit Berufsmaturität.
Das dauert vier Jahre. Danach mache
ich wahrscheinlich die Passerelle.
Medizin ist auf jeden Fall
immer noch ein Thema.
Das möchtest du studieren?
- Ja.
Welches wäre die Alternative?
Informatik.
Dich interessiert immer noch beides?
- Ja.
Erinnerst du dich noch an deinen
ersten Tag in der Schweiz?- Ja.
Wie fühlte sich das damals an?
Ich rechnete eigentlich nie damit,
dass ich so viel erreichen würde.
Aber am ersten Tag war mir gar nicht
klar, wie schwierig es sein würde.
Das wurde mir erst später klar.
Was war das Schwierigste?
- Die Sprache.
Neue Freunde zu finden
und mich zu integrieren.
Aber jetzt ...
... ist das kein Thema mehr.
* Ammar spricht arabisch. *
Für die Kinder verblassen
die Erinnerungen an Syrien langsam.
Die Grossmutter
kennen sie nur noch von Whatsapp.
* Lachen,
die Grossmutter spricht arabisch. *
* Sie sprechen arabisch. *
(Kusai) Ich telefoniere
regelmässig mit meinen Grosseltern.
Aber ansonsten ...
... verbindet mich
nicht sehr viel mit Syrien,
abgesehen
von meinen Verwandten dort.
Und was bedeutet dir die Sprache,
das Arabische?
Ich bin
mit dieser Sprache aufgewachsen,
aber Deutsch
gefällt mir schon besser.
Ich spreche auch
besser Deutsch als Arabisch.
Tatsächlich?
- Ja.
Ja ...
... er spricht
besser Deutsch als Arabisch.
Ich glaube,
er war neun oder zehn Jahre alt,
als wir in die Schweiz kamen.
Daher spricht er besser Deutsch
bzw. Berndeutsch als Arabisch.
Judi kann auch
nicht so gut Arabisch.
Kusai ist besser als Judi.
Judi ist eine Katastrophe.
* Lachen *
Vieles hat sich verändert
seit ihren Anfängen in der Schweiz.
Wie gross sind unsere Chancen,
Arbeit zu finden?
(Kusai) Sie haben keine Lust,
etwas zu machen.
Meine Mutter will sich am Handy
dauernd die Nachrichten ansehen.
(Raoaa) Das ist wichtig.
- Ja, aber ...
Wir können es
nicht einfach vergessen
und hier ein schönes Leben führen.
Verstehst du, dass er sagt:
"Ich will nicht mehr"?
Ja, das tut weh.
Das ist gar kein Thema mehr für sie.
Sie hängen viel weniger am Handy.
Falls doch,
lesen sie nicht nur Nachrichten,
sondern nutzen das Handy
v.a. zur Unterhaltung.
Sie haben
fast keine Zeit mehr dafür.
Natürlich ist es wichtig,
die Nachrichten
immer noch zu verfolgen,
aber wir verfolgen sie
nicht mehr so extrem wie früher.
Das war schädlich.
Was soll ich sagen?
Vielleicht hingen wir früher
dauernd am Handy,
weil wir sehr viel Zeit hatten.
Aber dann habe ich
eine Stelle gefunden
und Raoaa hat auch Arbeit gefunden.
Daher hatten wir
keine Zeit mehr dafür.
Aber nun habe ich wieder viel Zeit.
Jetzt ist es wieder so wie damals.
- Momentan.
Ammar hat pandemiebedingt
seine Stelle verloren
und sucht immer noch Arbeit.
Raoaa hat dafür gute Nachrichten.
Sie will
ihrem Laufbahnberater mitteilen,
dass ihr endlich
eine Festanstellung zugesagt wurde.
Mit dem Kopftuch
eine Stelle zu finden, klappte nicht.
Also handelte sie.
Ich integriere mich natürlich,
aber nicht unter Zwang.
Mein Kopftuch hat
nicht unbedingt mit Religion zu tun.
Es hat eher mit Kultur,
Gewohnheit und Tradition zu tun.
Daher habe ich
eine Zwischenlösung gewählt:
Ich bedecke meine Haare
mit einer Mütze,
damit ich weniger Probleme habe.
So habe ich mehr Chancen
in Bezug auf die Stellensuche,
die Ausbildung etc.
Was sie arbeitet, ist eher zufällig.
Der Job in dem Behinderten-
wohnheim war das einzige Angebot.
Als Lehrerin hat sie keine Chancen
und für Ausbildungen
fehlen ihr die Papiere.
So ...
Was gibt es Neues?
Ich habe eine neue Stelle gefunden.
- Tatsächlich?
Ja.
Das ist super. Gratulation.
Danke. Ich freue mich auch.
Ich war überrascht,
als man mir das mitgeteilt hat.
Das Problem bei der Festanstellung
ist der Arbeitsweg von täglich 3 Std.
Aber wenn ich keine
andere Chance bekomme ...- Voilà.
... dann will ich diese Chance
ergreifen und nicht warten.
Dadurch habe ich die Möglichkeit,
mich zu beweisen.
Zudem ist es motivierend.
Ich fühle mich
nicht mehr so eingesperrt,
sondern kriege endlich die Chance,
die ich schon lange gebraucht hätte,
um weiterzukommen.
Um Gas geben zu können.
- Ja, genau.
Und es geht immer weiter.
Ammar hat im April 2021
seinen Temporärjob zurückbekommen
und nach langem Hin und Her
können sie endlich in eine
grössere Wohnung in Köniz ziehen.
(Raoaa) Salam aleikum.
Kurz vor Weihnachten.
Familie Nasser ist angekommen in
der neuen Wohnung und im neuen Leben.
Dies ist mein Zimmer.
Das hier war eigentlich
bei meinem Bruder,
aber er braucht es nicht mehr.
Daher ist es jetzt bei mir.
Dies ist mein Pult,
das ich vor Kurzem bekommen habe.
Hier mache ich Hausaufgaben.
Früher machte ich sie im Wohnzimmer.
Wir sind seit sieben Jahren
in der Schweiz
und ich habe seit drei Monaten
ein eigenes Zimmer.
Das ist praktisch.
Wenn ich etwas
für mich allein machen will,
muss ich nicht mehr
ins Zimmer meines Bruders gehen.
Zudem habe ich mehr Platz für
meine Sachen. Es ist praktischer.
Der Familienzuwachs ist ein Geschenk
einer Arbeitskollegin von Raoaa.
Und Judis grösstes Glück.
Das Wichtigste:
Die Zeit der Arbeitslosigkeit und
der temporären Anstellung ist vorbei.
Ammar wurde
eine Festanstellung zugesagt.
Meine Chef rief mich an und sagte:
"Hey, ich habe
gute Nachrichten für dich."
"Du kannst wieder zurückkommen."
Danach rief ich Raoaa an.
Ich war sehr glücklich.
Sehr glücklich.
Es ist eine Katastrophe,
wenn ein Mann in der Schweiz
keine Arbeit hat.
Ich bin stolz,
dass ich nun selbstständig und nicht
mehr vom Sozialamt abhängig bin.
Das Wichtigste war ...
Als ich hier ankam, konnte ich
nicht verstehen und akzeptieren,
dass ich eine Bittstellerin
sein soll,
obwohl ich viel weiss und kann.
Sich integrieren heisst auch,
einen Weg zu finden,
mit beiden Kulturen umzugehen.
Sinnbild dafür
ist im Moment ein Christbaum
in der Wohnung
der muslimischen Familie.
Wenn ich Freundinnen besuchte, sah
ich dort immer einen Weihnachtsbaum.
Das sah total schön aus.
Einmal durfte ich bei einer Freundin
beim Schmücken des Baums mithelfen.
Ich fragte meine Mutter, ob wir
auch einen Baum haben können.
Sie wusste nicht genau,
was ich meinte.
* Lachen *
Dann zeigte ich ihr ein paar Fotos.
Meine Eltern waren nicht böse,
sondern erlaubten mir
einen Weihnachtsbaum.
Es bleibt kompliziert.
Feiern sie den Kindern
zuliebe Weihnachten,
gibt es
mit den syrischen Verwandten Ärger.
Manche waren erstaunt,
manche schockiert,
manche akzeptierten es gar nicht
und andere akzeptierten es sofort.
Kulturelle Spannungsfelder
werden bleiben.
In ihrem grössten Wunsch
unterscheiden sie sich nicht
von anderen Familien:
Mein grösster Wunsch ist,
dass meine ganze Familie
gesund bleibt ...
... und dass ich lerne,
Berndeutsch zu verstehen.
D.h., wenn du Berndeutsch kannst,
lebst du hier im Kanton Bern?
Ja.
- Nicht in Syrien?
Äh, willst du die Wahrheit hören?
Nein, hier. Was soll ich dort?
Ich vermisse meine Familie
und meine Mutter.
Aber was soll ich dort?
Es gibt keine Sicherheit.
Es ist immer noch Krieg.
Es ist eine Katastrophe
und kein Leben.
Wenn ich mal genug habe
und wenn sich die Lage
in Syrien verändert
bzw. wenn es wieder
so wird wie vorher,
ist Syrien schon ein Thema für mich.
Ich denke, in zehn Jahren
werde ich immer noch in Bern leben,
aber alleine bzw. hoffentlich
mit einer Frau an meiner Seite.
Das ist klar.
Auf keinen Fall eine Araberin.
* Lachen *
Uff, das wäre
sehr, sehr anstrengend.
Er kennt seine Mutter.
Daher will er keine Araberin.
Fies.
(Fernsehbeitrag)
Die humanitäre Situation in Mariupol
ist besorgniserregend.
Diese Bilder aus einem Spital
sind von gestern.
Im März 2022 drängt sich
der Russland-Ukraine-Krieg
auch in die Stube
von Familie Nasser in Köniz.
(Fernsehbeitrag)
Aber das stimmt nicht.
Krieg macht alles kaputt.
Leider.
Der Horror.
Es ist einfach der Horror.
Ein Trauma.
Die Ukrainer denken vielleicht,
dass sie nach ein oder zwei Monaten
wieder zurück nach Hause können.
Das wird leider nicht so sein.
Meine Frau und ich
haben zuerst auch gedacht,
der Krieg sei
nach ein oder zwei Wochen zu Ende.
Aber leider dauert er in Syrien
nun schon zehn oder elf Jahre.
Daher ... Keine Ahnung. Das sind
auf jeden Fall arme Menschen.
Was erwartet diese Leute eigentlich?
Sie sind jetzt
zwar in einem sicheren Land,
aber was erwartet sie später noch?
Für mich
bleiben Flüchtlinge Flüchtlinge.
Ich z.B. habe eine gute Stelle
und habe mich gut integriert,
aber letztlich
bin ich doch immer ein Flüchtling.
Fühlst du dich angesprochen, wenn
du das Wort Flüchtling hörst?- Nein.
Eigentlich nicht.
Aber wenn man
mit mir darüber spricht,
habe ich schon das Gefühl ...
Dann habe ich schon das Gefühl,
ein Flüchtling zu sein.
Aber sonst eigentlich nicht.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Manuela Waldner - 2022